[Musique]
les représentants des organismes publics
et privés sont réunis pour inaugurer le
comité départemental des services aux
familles de la réunion une instance qui
conseille organise et répond aux besoins
des familles en leur proposant les
services les plus adaptés nous avons
aussi un devoir et une responsabilité
envers les familles réunionnaises c'est
de bien accompagner tous les marmailles
de la réunion si tenté qu'il y avait des
problèmes de trouver des solutions pour
que chaque enfant qui naît à la réunion
et les meilleures chances de réussir sa
vie et donc non participation au sein de
ce comité départemental est essentielle
nous sommes nous sommes là dans un rôle
de joker même je dirais de nos priorités
un comité qui regroupe entre autres les
principaux acteurs sociaux comme l'état
le département la caf la rs la mise en
commun des compétences et des ressources
répondra plus efficacement aux besoins
des familles au travers de la prévention
et de la protection de l'enfance la
non-soumission ford pour aller voir si
les chaînes nationales
en finale
d'accession
qualitatif dont elles ont besoin pour
les accompagner dans leur famille aussi
bien en matière d'une bataille plus
jeunes enfants mais aussi de soutiens
l'euro
le développement
des services innovante était présenté
comme le bébébus des microcrèches
mobiles qui se rendront au plus près des
familles isolées afin de leur proposer
un mode d'accueil temporaire le comité
départemental des services aux familles
de la réunion a fait de la prévention
des violences faites aux enfants et aux
jeunes une de ces causes prioritaires
[Musique]